what would you tell viewers as to why
they should watch this show well I think
because there's someone and performances
in it namely clairvoyant on this guy um
no look there's some great performances
I think for me I sort of learned
something new about our culture and
history and I think emotionally it's a
story that we think we know even that we
do know that actually we don't know yeah
if that makes any sense
probably darling and I think the thing
is very difficult to define because
there's something unique about it you
just don't know what it is because you
do watch it expecting to be like oh here
we go
you know I know everything that happened
and then you just it's somehow it is
skewed and you don't know how and it's
just made by the most extraordinary
people yes it's written by Peter Morgan
it's directed by Stephen Daldry it's
that's off I mean that's given a star
yeah it really is get one and then throw
into the fact that they're Royals at
extraordinary locations and costumes and
costumes related events and people and
just it's just business magic hands in
is doing the music and Zimmer now we
just sound like ourselves
people forget that you know Queen
Elizabeth and Prince Philip had a life
before and the life they have now and
what was the most surprising thing that
you found out about your characters that
you didn't already know I must say I
didn't know that they'd gone to Malta
and just lived in Malta for kind of like
five years well while you were having
your navel crowing that you were gonna
be the youngest Admiral of the fleet
yeah she just went down the show so I
went to shops at my hair done oh yeah
was a normal princess mm-hmm yeah I
didn't ever intend for the Navy he was
in the Navy yeah he was a real naval man
I don't feel like also if you look back
any further into his history it's really
fascinating like he was he was born on a
kitchen table in Greece exiled he left
in an orange crate he then was sort of
moved around all these different homes
and stuff he had a fascinating life his
mother was committed his father went off
to Monaco with him with a mistress year
it was really um well you know with a
mistress us a bit salacious but he went
off to Monaco and all the same yeah
sleep fascinating fascinating
fascinating what did you do to kind of
push up accent well there were certain
phrases and things that would help you
sort of get in to it that's that's very
true actually
just a little sentence that I underlined
Jay what wheels Olympic Olympic Olympic
yes because he would um there's a bit of
like footage of him talking about
opening the Olympics and he says Olympic
a nut so what's yours Fox's
communication badi-ma yes whether any
items that you wanted to like take home
with you or you were like I tell you
others
Oh what happened lovely twins that I
really some not definitely lapels nicer
like a good jumper and a car to go okay
hi oh you have some lovely things
regarding their text like 50s oh that
was nice as a sports sort of t-shirts
which are amazing which I tried to get
denied an excel disease this is a
fashion magazine isn't it yeah good
sports
t-shirts guys yeah they were pretty cool
and like the high-waisted trousers are
pretty creamy yeah I got really into
actually it are there any other Netflix
shows that you guys are watching at the
moment yeah a strange thing greatest
thing this is amazing narcos is amazing
okay love knocking I did a black mirror
last night did you got to watch it I
don't watch that I'm Amanda Knox
documentary is it yep yeah it's pretty
and pretty intense yeah I need to get me
to yeah yeah um yeah very good much
thank you so much
let me try
you